hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and i'm excited to talk a little
bit about safe browsing our guest today
is kelly hope harrington who's a senior
staff software engineer at google kelly
welcome
thank you happy to be here
so safe browsing you know my sense of
browser we you go to some websites it
sends up some web pages what's the worst
that can happen
oh well there there's all sorts of bad
things that can happen on the internet
um and i think some of the ones that
that are come to mind first are things
like phishing or social engineering so
someone is trying to trick you into
thinking there's someone you trust so
you share either your personal
information like your password or your
credit card information or maybe you do
something that you wouldn't otherwise do
because you trust them
and that could be something like
downloading installing malware so
malware is something that will
take over your computer the attacker is
trying to do something to get value out
of you so maybe they want to take some
of your personal data and sell it on the
dark web maybe they want to do
ransomware where they lock down your
computer and won't let you use it until
you pay them money or maybe they want to
do something sneakier and do crypto
mining in the background so your
computer gets hot and slow while you're
while that's happening
we also see unwanted software so on its
software might have something that you
do value but also does something else
yeah so i just want to make sure i
understand this because we talk in other
videos about phishing where someone
pretends to send you an emergency letter
from a bank or whatever and many of
those phishing attacks usually try to
get you to some type of a website
and this is where once again you're
browsing now you need to make sure that
that's actually the website that you
think it is yeah yeah you know i think
that you know the attackers know you're
looking for stuff so they're trying to
take advantage of your you're already
naturally trying to go and download
something and that is their opportunity
to try and trick you and try and get you
to do something that you weren't
otherwise going to do super helpful